That's a misinterpretation, mislication
of the passage. Jesus Christ the Lord
does not say we will never get sick or
disease. His promise to us is if we
truly love the Lord Jesus Christ and
we're truly connected to the Lord Jesus
Christ and obviously we don't love him
perfectly, but we're striving to. He
will give us the grace to endure. He
will preserve us in spite of what we go
through. He doesn't mean he will
necessarily save us from getting sick.
But if we do get sick and he permits it,
he'll give us the grace and the power to
endure it even if that sickness results
in our physical death. And I'll prove
that to you from scripture that there's
nothing in the Bible that guarantees
that no Christian will ever suffer. And
it doesn't mean if you get sick or if
you suffer that's because of some
unrepentant unconfessed sin in your
life. The Lord Jesus can discipline you
for sins that you are not repenting of.
Sins that you're indulging willfully
even though you know it's sinful and
grieves the Holy Spirit. But not
everyone gets sick. And again, I want to
emphasize this. It's not just for you. I
want everyone to hear this. I'm trusting
the Holy Spirit to save me from error
and anoint me to speak truth clearly,
interpret God's word correctly, and live
it out in Jesus name. Because everything
good is from the spirit.
I just want to
emphasize if you're sick that's not
necessarily because of unrepentant
unconfessed sin or you lack faith. It
can be that. But again, it may be simply
God permitting you to get sick. Not so
much because he's disciplining you for
unrepentant sin, but to also teach you
to trust in him and to take you to a
higher level of dependency on Christ. to
trust in him even when you're sick that
he's with you and give you the grace
either either to overcome the sickness
or if it's God's will for you to enter
glory through that sickness he will not
leave nor forsake you but give you the
grace to endure it because ultimately
our citizenship is in heaven meaning we
are strangers sojouring in a strange
land this fallen earth is not ours new
heavens and the new earth will be our
everlasting possession and the new
heavens and new earth where God
transforms this fallen creation.
There'll be no more sin, no more
disease, no more pain, no more
suffering, no more Satan. That is our
inheritance. But until the new heavens,
new earth and this fallen world that is
plagued by Satan sin and because of sin
and Satan bodies are perishing and
decaying, we will suffer the effects of
the fall. But then ultimately in the new
heavens and new earth, there is no more
curse. But now let me give you biblical
passages to confirm this because I said
a mouthful. Let's take this step by
step. Let's let's focus on this question
folks. Let's go to 2 Corinthians 12 7
to10 and thank our brother first Lance.
He'll be posting for me. So 2
Corinthians 12 7
to10. Let me take it step by step. Okay.
First of all, if you do get sick or if
you do get a virus, that's not
necessarily because God is punishing you
because of some sin or because you're
weak in your faith. Because here you see
2 Corinthians 12 7-10. Unless I should
be exalted above measure through the
abundance of the revelations, there was
given to me a thorn in the flesh. This
is Paul talking about the Lord Jesus
using his trials, his suffering to keep
him humble, to keep him teachable and
keep him dependent on the grace of the
Lord Jesus Christ, lest he becomes
puffed up and he thinks of himself more
highly than he should because apart from
Jesus Christ, we're absolutely nothing.
Now, pay attention to what Paul says.
The Lord Jesus permitted allowed an
angel of Satan to torment Paul to prick
Paul. Now Paul doesn't tell us the
nature of his affliction from this evil,
wicked, unclean spirit. Now, how do I
know it's an evil, wicked, unclean
spirit? Let's read. Given to me a thorn
in the flesh, the messenger of Satan.
Those of you who read the Greek New
Testament, you'll see that the word
messenger here is the same word for
angel. That's why other translations
render this passage as an angel of
Satan, an angel under the order of
Satan, an angel who works for Satan. An
angel who's part of the kingdom of
darkness, the kingdom of evil, who
receives orders from Satan, his Lord.
So, this is an evil angel, an evil
spirit given authority by Christ. In
other words, Christ allowing him to
torment
Paul to cause Paul suffering in his
flesh. What was that suffering? Was it a
disease? We don't know because Paul
doesn't go into detail, but it says, "A
messenger of saint to buffet me lest I
should be exalted above measure. For
this thing I besought the Lord thrice."
Three times I asked the Lord. I prayed
to the Lord, "Lord, deliver me from this
that it might depart from me." And he
said unto me, "My grace is sufficient
for thee, for my strength is made
perfect in weakness." Now notice what he
goes on to say, latter part of uh verse
9. Most gladly, therefore, will I rather
glory in my infirmities, that the power
of Christ may rest upon me. Therefore, I
take pleasure in infirmities and
reproaches. I delight when people insult
me. I take pleasure when I have a
sickness or a human ailment.
Right? In necessities, even when I'm in
need, I rejoice and I delight. And when
I'm persecuted, I rejoice and I delight.
When I'm experiencing distresses like
this pandemic, this panic, I rejoice, I
delight, I am joyful. Why? For Christ's
sake. For when I am weak, then I am
strong. Now, let me break it down for
everyone. And I hope you're paying
attention, guys. This is where I need
you to pay attention. Don't be
distracted. Let's focus on the word of
God, trusting the spirit to bless this
session. Okay? Listen to what Paul is
saying here.
One of the ways in which the Lord Jesus
kept me humble did not allow me to get
proud preventing me from then being
condemned because of pride and conceit.
He allowed me to experience a physical
infirmity. Pay attention here. The
wisdom of the Lord Jesus. How he works
in our lives to make us more like him
and depend on him and trust in him. So
there's this physical infirmity that was
brought upon by an angel of Satan. So
learn guys, pay attention. learn that
some diseases, some physical infirmities
are the result the work of the kingdom
of darkness. In other words, what you
learn here is that Satan and evil
spirits do have the power and the
authority to inflict people with
physical infirmities, physical ailments
and diseases. Is that
clear? Before I move on, is that clear
to everyone? Before I move on,
So it is clear right? Okay. So the
spirit realm both the demonic realm and
the righteous angels of God do have
power and authority to inflict people
with ailments with diseases with
viruses. That's number one. Number two,
why did the Lord allow an evil spirit to
inflict Paul with a physical infirmity?
This was Jesus's way of saving Paul from
falling into the sin of pride and being
condemned. You understand that? So Paul
wasn't afflicted and inflicted with this
infirmity because he had sinned. He was
afflicted with this infirmity so that he
would not end up sinning. It was God's
way of saving him from sinning and come
coming under God's condemnation. That's
the second point before I move on. Did
everyone get
that? Before I move
on. So, was Paul afflicted with this
physical infirmity by an evil spirit
because he had sin? Or because this was
Jesus's way of saving him from falling
into the sin of pride? Now, how did this
affliction prevent Paul from sinning
against Christ? Because Paul then
realize he's utterly
weakless. Weak, I'm sorry. Utterly weak.
Helpless is the word. As Holy Spirit
protects me from error. hopeless and
utterly weak and nothing apart from
Christ. In other words, this was Jesus's
way of teaching him everything good you
have, everything good you do, everything
praiseworthy you've accomplished. It's
because of my power. It's because the
Holy Spirit in you. Don't take credit
for your achievements. Don't get puffed
up and think as if it's something you've
done in your own strength. Cuz apart
from me, Paul, you are nothing. Apart
from me, Paul, you are utterly weak and
helpless and hopeless. Apart from me,
Paul, you are a maggot and a worm. All
the great things you've done,
praiseworthy things you've done, things
that delight God, you did because of my
power, because of my strength, because
of my grace, because of my love, and
because of the Holy Spirit in you. So,
what did you learn here? Sometimes the
Lord Jesus will allow you to be
afflicted to prevent you from sinning
and also to teach you to depend on
Christ to trust in Christ because it's
Christ who empowers you to do the things
that are good in the sight of God and it
is Christ who preserves you for his
glory. So did we learn that
here? Everyone learn
this? So excellent question, but I'm
going to build on this question. I'm not
done yet.
And notice when Paul said, "Take it away
from me." Jesus didn't take it
away. He said, "No, I will allow this to
afflict you in order to teach you to
depend on me and endure." So here you
learn that Jesus won't necessarily save
you from affliction, but give you the
grace and the power to undergo an
affliction without that affliction
destroying your faith.
Making sense?